oui c'est à dire que pourquoi ce record
de candidatures moi j'y vois deux
explications majeures l'une plus majeur
que lot mais l'autre qu'il faut quand
même souligner la première c'est le
résultat d'une balkanisation du du
système politique
avant on avait une droite et une gauche
aujourd'hui on a deux gauche une gauche
plus tôt jacobine une gauche plus tôt
girondine macro compatibles et on a deux
droites une droite
alors quitte à en péril aujourd'hui une
droite plutôt bonapartiste c'est dur qui
est plutôt incarné par une forme de
marinisme front national et une droite
plus orléaniste compatibles et entre 2 à
une tentative de jongler notamment chez
les républicains
avant on avait instruit un paysage
politique beaucoup plus structuré et au
sein de ses frais de ces deux c4 miettes
si vous voulez vous avez également des
lignes de fractions forte c'est à dire
qu'on les pensait à peu près unis après
les présidentielles
la wac et des scissions front national
il y a également des ruptures forte au
sein des républicains le parti
socialiste et entre part entre parti
communiste et jean luc mélenchon
les choses ne vont pas non plus très
bien tout ça favorise la multiplication
plus en plus cette question de faute il
ou pas faire alliance avec en marche
tous a conduit à une multiplication la
deuxième source de balkanisation des
listes l ailier tout bêtement à la
parité et au scrutin proportionnel parce
que lorsque vous voulez avoir
deux élus masculin ou féminin mais
généralement plutôt masculins qui sont
élus sénateurs dans un mode de scrutin
proportionnel vous avez une solution
très simple c'est de faire de liste
étant donné que vos deux listes peuvent
éventuellement arrive en tête ou avoir
des scores raisonnables et bien tout
d'un coup mathématiquement et bien vous
avez vos de tête masculine qui sont élus
ce n'est pas la formule la plus générale
mais tout de même il y à il y à un
certain nombre de listes dont on
soupçonne qu'elle ait choisi ce mode de